il ya en ce moment sept mille trois
cents véhicules électriques ou hybrides
rechargeables exactement sur nos routes
québec veut faire passer ce chiffre à
100 milles d'ici 2020 dans cinq ans donc
vincent maisonneuve
philippe couillard présenté cet après
midi les nouveaux objectifs de son
gouvernement en matière
d'électrification des transports et on
va investir sur cinq ans 420 millions
l'argent je vous dirais qu'il va surtout
servir à maintenir des programmes
existants comme entre autres cette
subvention qui va jusqu'à 8000 $ si vous
achetez un véhicule tout électrique ou
encore le déploiement de bornes de
recharge du côté d'hydro-québec
il ya quelques petites nouveautés très
intéressantes entre autres la
possibilité si vous avez un véhicule
électrique de rouler en tout temps sur
les voies réservées sur les autoroutes
la région de montréal les ponts à péage
de l'a 25 et de latran dans la grande
région de montréal sont également
gratuits si vous avez un véhicule
électrique et les traversiers du québec
seront également gratuit pour ceux qui
ont les plaques vertes donc des
véhicules électriques
le gros morceau cette annonce sur ce
plan viendra sans doute plus tard
puisque le premier ministre a également
annoncé la volonté du gouvernement d'y
aller d'aller de l'avant avec une loi
zéro émission qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est une loi zéro émission ça veut dire
si une loi qui coupent qui pourrait
contraindre les constructeurs
automobiles à vendre certain pourcentage
de véhicules électriques au québec mais
les les paramètres de ce projet du
gouvernement demeurent floues on écoute
là dessus le premier ministre fait les
brouillards savais que ça prend une
législation s'apprennent encadrement
réglementaire mais on veut le faire
avait également avec des partenaires
alors on en parle avec nos voisins de
l'ontario qui en passant est une réalité
économique différente d'un autre parce
que ils ont l'industrie automobile
traditionnelle chez eux donc ça
représente un facteur de tension que
nous on ne peut pas on veut parler
également notre secteur économique
également mais on va aller de l'avant
dans la norme vers la norme zeev et
danse qui aura les échéances et plus
précis à vous les communiquerons
le chef de l'opposition considère qu'une
telle loi devrait être adoptée beaucoup
plus rapidement parce que pendant ce
temps là patrice les constructeurs
automobiles réserve plusieurs de leurs
modèles électriques à des marchés à des
secteurs des régions où on a déjà des
lois qui les force à vendre des voitures
électriques comme la californie et
pendant ce temps là les acheteurs
québécois doivent attendre souvent assez
longtemps avant se procurer véhicules
électriques
très bien merci vincent je vous en prie